how long in the staff guy remember it so
you don't have to well it's that DVD
review time again and you know what that
means I had to find something public
domain to look at
or else I'm decapitating Hollywood well
you know what I don't want to yeah fuck
it I mean I'm sick of looking over
crappy side by a forties propaganda I
want to do something current popular and
something I even ask permission for hey
Brad can't review paranoia go fuck a
horse thanks
this is paranoid you ever wonder what
would happen if the cinema snob turned
to one of those pretentious filmmakers
he makes fun of the darkest recesses of
my nightmares won't allow me to think
about it but luckily this film exists to
show me what the outcome would be
it has sex murder mayhem and probably
the biggest collection of bearded men
since the last temptation of Christ but
is it on par with main writer and actor
Brad Jones's other work well he does
keep his cat out of most of the shots
let's get our freak on with paranoia so
we open up with Jones before he looked
like a retired bobble head as he plays a
character named Mark oh hi mark
he's upset because his wife is leaving
and thus he's out of a free meal ticket
at some point over the last five years
it had to be good wasn't it I never said
it wasn't
you never said anything he always locked
away writing I'm trying to make a career
in the five years since you've met you
never finished anything I took a second
job to cover bills to pay for this house
I put aside things I wanted I put them
aside because I was supporting you oh
come on a spouse supporting a freelance
writer who would believe that get over
it mark
it's never gonna fucking happen yeah to
be fair she does this every time she
watches short circuit two
be safe I hope you're happy you too
I can't really last time I was
so while walking pass a piece done by
renowned deviant artist Harley Quinn fan
two six one seven mark sits around
pondering his life yeah he's also
wondering hmm if she's the one
supporting me then how come I'm the one
staying at the really nice house
Pat Knight Christ
yeah then credibly light knock was
pretty startling message for use up he
finds a person who seems to have been
shot dead but maybe he's not entirely
dead maybe he's just half dead
no that's better and now back to the
ground he goes next door to try and call
the police but has a rough time
convincing his neighbor John I really
don't mean to bother you but could I
possibly use your cell phone for a
minute or two you want to use my cell
phone yeah
who are you calling why at 12:30 I have
the right to ask the police just got it
mark and tell me the truth you're
calling your wife right
Marissa left me and that's not why I
need to use the phone I need to call the
police John pay me five dollars for
watching I'm so glad this conversation
about the phone is here it just moves
forward so much character development
and story and raises so many tormenting
questions like real mark ever give a
cell phone
buy a cell phone market I don't want a
fucking cell phone
but mark quickly realizes this house
seems a little cordless fuck I'm not
really bleeding all that bad actually if
I was I might have already been dead by
now
kinda goes without saying I mean isn't
it kind of like going I didn't lose my
penis if I did I couldn't pee
the stranger tries to cop a feel but
mark just says no two thugs
hey here's a fun drinking game take a
shot every time he takes a shot if he
gets to go through this movie drunk why
can't I well nothing better to do after
a few strong ones then go for a nice
leisurely Drive it's good body dumping
weather
this is 373 point fives
soothing music for your homicidal
psychotic beat this one for you mark if
you're listening it's paranoia paranoia
everybody's coming together he gets
pulled over by a police officer who I
swear to god is the guy he just shot is
that his doppelganger you know your uh
left taillights out no I won't work your
ticket this time but you need to take
that in get that fixed ASAP and by the
way have you seen my twin brother he's a
very eccentric Jehovah's Witness who has
a strange way of converting people
door-to-door she want to pop the trunk I
can take a look at it right now
sometimes the chords just jiggle loose
no no no no I I don't want to trouble
you I was planning on going to the
service station anyway I was thinking we
could take care of it here and brainerd
he goes to a Fixit shop after he pulls
the dead body into the front seat that's
less conspicuous and he is the guy to
fix up the taillight keys what by the
way boys and girls today's secret word
is what or huh
trust me they're used all the time
during this friggin flick what what what
huh what what what huh what what what
huh he uses it more times than a deaf
person
your blood no it's the dead person I
killed Oh can I give believe that
question got me I wonder the I just hang
in there man it's not like you're gonna
die don't let things get to you every
time there's a salacious story in the
news people get worried even paranoid
it's part of what makes us human
thank you toilet psychiatrist was he
reading a dr. Phil book while he's
sitting in there don't you see what
you're doing to your family mark you're
overeating is hurting them as well as
you now I expect to see a drastic loss
of weight in the next two years get
cracking so after he leaves the everyday
car place that puts black garbage bags
on their doors he drops off his friend
eddakath and decides to go home to the
person he's just killed Tom why I'm not
really sure maybe he just want to know
what kind of guy would have the nerve to
be shot by him or maybe used to have a
relatively pointless scene like this one
friend of Carl's in a way okay well I'm
just returning this to him so she gives
him this a screwdriver used on Star Trek
and he decides to roam the streets
coming across an old friend of the past
five minutes Oh
taillight right I stopped in to get some
cigarettes and the machines broke is
that so here I don't know what to say
thank you yeah well I quit yeah I quit
that's why I have two in my pocket
you all right man just a headache
so as Jones's acting continues to go
Shatner he decides to drop by a
restaurant where the waitress seems very
talkative here you go my house Thanks
Wow free water this place rocks you
don't mind do you
yeah I guess music in a restaurant is
pretty bizarre well you heard about the
body right they found a body yeah
Chatham Heights killer strikes again a
killer is on the loose and it is dark as
fuck outside I mean what more could I
ask for my marriage falls apart and
instead of running after I'm wandering
the streets thinking to myself if it
weren't so terrifying what a great story
this would make nah not even a guy who
reviews porn for a living would come up
with something like that but they're
then approached by I swear the whitest
gang you will ever see in your life
I'm not kidding they drive up in a
minivan two of them were wearing glasses
and even the driver looks like the
younger sister of one of the gang
members can I have the plane oh please
no just shut up a blue Angry Birds they
bust in and take the waitress hostage
but mark is in no mood to have his free
water drinking interrupted
hey careful those pellets hurt yeah
my mama be a bitch huh me and qua why
would she be scared she knows what they
were doing and that she'd have to make a
quick getaway mama be a bitch
oh I'm sorry I'm a phony of people
asking me to drive them don't worry
about
no they tried to do was kill me it's not
so bad so obviously they have to call
the cops right no we should not call the
cops
and why not I do not want to take the
blame for this you kill anybody in this
world and you're not a cop your
reputation will be ruined that is how
things work yeah that really high-end
reputation of being unknown getting
nothing published and being supported by
your not wife sounds like you got a lot
to lose there I just got an idea so they
make up a lie and make it look like the
waitress who also seems to be the cook
seeing how nobody else is in this place
was the only one who stopped them you're
taking his gun don't worry but the
bullets at this gun hasn't been fired
you're worried about the bullets from
the gun and not the obvious fingerprints
you're leaving behind play let's pray
suicides as stupid as the show CSI so
all these dead bodies is getting
repetitive you know what'll mix it up
another dead body yeah he comes across
the body of a dead kid in the middle of
a field and I'm guessing that's a desire
version of CPR you got lucky you know
what you're up there I'm down here well
he's right assume you're up there you
know when I was a kid I used to camp out
at my grandma's house just gazing up at
the night sky staring at the stars for
hours you know it really says something
when laying with the corpse of a dead
kid is the heartwarming part of your
movie but to be fair we get back to our
more traditional fucked up this when
Mark seems to suddenly be in a dance
club trying to discover if there's a way
to make white dancing even more awkward
could be a lucky night
perhaps you'd like to take your pick
variety is the major of choice um were
those women just on standby for whenever
he snapped all right ladies you go flirt
with the men at the bar you go flirt
with him in on the dance floor you just
wait and deafening silence until I snap
my fingers that means I'm about to sell
you for sex ooh he must have picked a
good one apparently she has four stars
thank you
he seems to fantasize about having his
way with her and even about how to kill
her which I guess turns her on but he
slowly snaps out and wakes up at home
could you close the door Harvey thank
you shit oh oh there's that bear again
this isn't possible
you're dead
ah I love a mark scream is on par with a
geeky teenager from Simpsons oh if I had
a girlfriend she kill me boy they sure
are sending a pretty little thing
tonight aren't they
sorry so we see an alternate version of
the scene we just saw
ah how dare you show that I like women
so he turns off the soundtrack turns off
the TV he even turns off the doorbell
which happens to be connected to the
t1000 door the t1000
boy I'd love to know how they got a
permit to film in this place
look father all we want to do is shoot a
movie about a man who kills people
breaks into their houses and sleeps with
prostitutes now if that's not doing the
Lord's work I don't know what is
oh come on what do you even tripod
maybe he tripped on his sin Oh mark I
was wondering if that was you what's
going on here
calm down mark it's only me
yeah come on it's only the guy who's
been scaring the shit out of you who
can't die I'm not calming down I want to
know what the fuck you're doing to my
life I haven't done anything to your
life what's she doing here oh and those
other people I saw tonight of equal
importance but what is she specifically
doing here I figured you might ask that
so he finally reveals will market then
going through the whole night after
somebody dies they go to one of two
places one of those places is eternal
bliss the other places like a continuing
nightmare reality blends in with the
fictitious and it suspends most of the
rules that occur in normal life so what
do you say you're in hell mark yes we
came up with that by combining three
Twilight Zone episodes they're dead yes
and this is all because of the killer
you're the killer what say what again I
fear you I double dare you motherfucker
so let's take a twist that could be
explained in two sentences and stretch
it out to none unnecessary twenty
minutes I remember what happened yes you
remember some of it I told you it's like
a nightmare sometimes reality can factor
into our fantasies
so just to clarify he's been dead the
whole time the earth is the plan of the
apes and he was always Tyler dirt oh and
demo real was just a plow shut up so it
seems like mark was the killer of all
these people the whole time for the
first time in your life you were in
control of something you felt a high
like nothing else you've ever felt
before
is it like the Pringles once you pop you
can't stop
hey I just killed my wife well you know
what they say when in Rome kill a bunch
of random people yeah that's the same I
don't know how many times I've told you
this already how many times is this
happened I've lost count
you know guys there are pews you could
go sit in them it's not like it's a full
house here hell even the dead people
figure that one out I'm just gonna leave
I'm just gonna walk up and go right out
that fucking door mark ladies and
gentlemen your paranoia players
screwdriver chick Carrie Kelly bearded
man number one cries at anything even a
number two world's widest gang member
for a sex with evolution talk awkward
priest and sister scary eyes good night
buddy can you give me a ride that's my
job - white taxi driver now I know this
isn't reality take me home I need to
talk to my wife no problem so kids
what's the bigger topic this movie
raises that hell is annoyingly confusing
or hell is confusingly annoying either
way it's an hour and a half you're never
getting back so how is paranoia oh I
think it's a bit of a required taste and
can be awkward at times but certainly
does create that sense of gloom and doom
that it obviously wants to capture it's
uncomfortable but in a good way like a
miserable night that just won't seem to
end and seeing how that's obviously what
the movie is trying to get across I'd
say it succeeded it's got his problems
sure but it does well at creating a
nightmarish world that seems to lumen
atmosphere so I'd say if a dark
unnerving trip down an alleyway of a
movie is your kind of flick go ahead and
check it out
I'm a nostalgia critic guy from it hello
hey asshole
I noticed you have a fucked a horse yet
because I found someone who's willing to
help it's gonna be doing dick feel like
carrots remember so you don't have
what
asshole movie was so perfect and he did
a writer's cut